[موسيقى]
نعم في المطار الخطير الآن
عمال النظافة شباب
المبلغ الذي جمعوه فيما بينهم
لقد أعطينا المال لمعلمنا المسؤول الديني مع الزلزال.
أعطى حقا للمساعدة
[موسيقى]
لقد وجد المال، وأعتقد أنه أحضره إلينا
مع مبلغ من المال
نحن نقوم بتنظيف المال عندما يتعلق الأمر بنا
بالليرة التركية فقط لأنهم وجدوها
كنا نظن أنهم جلبوا لنا
لاحقاً
عندما نحضر المال على الإفطار لا
لقد حدث زلزال في تركيا بعد هذا الزلزال
ولهذا السبب ذهبنا إلى هناك بوسائلنا الخاصة.
قائلا أريد أن أرسل المساعدة
أحضرت المال
[موسيقى]
مؤمننا المتأوه يعمل هنا من أجل
لا تذهبوا من هنا أيها الإخوة
أقول بارك الله فيهم
يا رب، دعونا نحافظ على هذه القوات حتى نهاية العالم.
أتمنى أن تستمر